it looks that way whatever he may wish
the prime minister head into parliament
to battle on but his party and his
cabinet now call in time on his
premiership questions prime minister
thank you mr speaker today is a big day
as we implement the biggest tax cut
for a decade a big day but not for the
reasons he might have hoped addressing
mps at prime minister's questions but
these days there's only one question
left when will he go i ask him to do the
honorable thing
to put the interests of the nation
before his own interest
and before in in his own words it does
become impossible for government to do
his job does the prime minister think
there are any circumstances in which he
should resign nothing um left for him to
do other than to take responsibility and
resign
the claps and cheers spoke volumes
i just say you want to be embarrassed by
clapping not embarrassed but this is
pain whatever the smirks and smiles try
to disguise the pm now in a brutal
battle as a wave of resignations put him
into freefall still trying though to
stand his ground the job of a prime
minister in difficult circumstances when
he's been handed a colossal mandate is
to keep going
but hour by hour that's becoming
increasingly difficult
anyone with anything about them would be
long gone from his front bench
[Applause]
in the middle of a crisis doesn't the
country deserve better than a zed-list
cast of nodding dogs isn't this the
first recorded case of the sinking ships
fleeing the rats the farce to flee sajid
javid now on the back benches preparing
to deliver what was a dam in resignation
speech treading the tight rope between
loyalty and integrity
has become impossible in recent months
and mr speaker i will never risk losing
my integrity
i also believe a team is as good as its
team captain
and that a captain is as good as his or
her team the events of recent months
have made it increasingly difficult to
be in that team
it's not fair
on ministerial colleagues to go out
every morning defending lines that don't
stand up and don't hold up
it's not fair on my parliamentary
colleagues who bear the brunt of
constituents dismay in their inboxes and
on their doorsteps in recent elections
and it's not fair
on conservative members and voters
who rightly expect better standards from
the party they supported parts of
solidarity for this man
and shouts of by boris as the prime
minister made a swift exit
from the chamber to his next grilling
from mps this not getting any easier
eight more members of the government
quitting while the prime minister sat in
this seat on his lapela terence higgins
trust badge but there's not much love
left here
when you see prime minister people like
um
john glenn leaving government people
like kemi badanok people like
neil o'brien do not feel prime minister
the very ability capacity of this
government to to address these enormous
overhanging issues
is is is deteriorating as we speak all
of it grim michael govers told you to go
they share heads up the game's up really
will you be prime minister tomorrow
of course
so sure even as some of his cabinet
began to gather in downing street
awaiting the pm's return grant chaps do
you want the prime minister to stand
down is that the honourable thing to do
sir
most here to tell him his time had come
do you still support the prime minister
nadine doris but this die-hard ally here
to rally him on there's a
delegation of your cabinet colleagues
waiting in downing street including the
chief whip the transport secretary and
your new chancellor
waiting to tell you when you finish here
today that it's time for you to go how
will you respond to that i'm not going
to give a a running commentary on
political events we're going to get on
with the government of the country
but running the country not easy right
now boris johnson tonight holed up in
there and full of defiance in the face
of almost certain defeat as ever this is
a politician who is breaking all
conventions and still believes that he
can defy political gravity stay in put
while others in his position would have
almost certainly walked by now but make
no mistake the past 24 hours seem to
have sealed his fate 38 government
resignations chunks of his cabinet and
his parliamentary party telling him he
has to go he doesn't want to leave but
this is now a prime minister who cannot
command his cabinet cannot command his
government cannot command his party and
cannot lead this country
this a politician now driven by only one
thing his visceral desire to remain in
number 10 but how long will his party
let him beth rigby sky news westminster
well beth rigby is here in a febrile
atmosphere certainly in downing street
and beth despite all of that boris
johnson utterly defiant tonight how is
he still here
anna he really is defiant tonight but we
were talking last night after those
cabinet resignations and the question
was is this the moment
where the end
is set for him where the die is cast and
we've had our answer haven't we in the
past 24 hours there have been now
42 resignations from his government my
piece to camera i only shot it half an
hour ago already out of day but he's
clinging on what is going on well
there's a couple of things going on
tonight at number one he sent his
parliamentary minister of lady james
dudderich out he spoke exclusively to
our john craig on sky news
and duddridge was saying uh that the
mood is buoyant in there it's business
as usual
there will be tax cuts in a prime
ministerial chancellor's speech next
week lots of people are going to be
given new roles so the message from in
there is we're plowing on what's the
message to the cabinet well the message
to the cabinet was to try and give them
short shrift tonight with michael gove
being sacked by boris johnson for this
morning suggesting to the prime minister
that it was time to set stand down now
the other group of cabinet ministers
that went in today you saw them all
going in grand chaps we had simon hart
brandon lewis not clear tonight what's
going to happen to them are they going
to resign sam my colleague talking about
another resignation tonight so the
cabinet is in a tussle with them and
then the parliamentary party well one
number 10 uh source told me tonight that
the prime minister meeting graeme brady
quoting this person called graham
brady's bluff
and the source says to me all graeme
could say is that there'll be an
election on monday for a new committee
there could be a change of rules there
could be a confidence vote boris johnson
could be ditched but it's not a given so
boris johnson the message to the party
on that is bring it on i mean it's
absolutely extraordinary and as i was
saying in my report tonight uh typically
uh a prime minister in this situation
would have stood down but boris johnson
is not a typical prime minister but
however defiant he is he is in deep
trouble and most people you speak to
pretty much all people you speak to
apart from the die hard loyalties say
the game is up